If you haven't seen the Hallelujah Flash Mob
yet, you've missed out. After one month, the
video already has 26 million views. One girl
starts singing, people get confused, a guy
joins in, and then BOOM, a host of secret
flash mob agents join in, and they handle
it pretty well.
But is the Hallelujah Flash Mob the best flash
mob of all time?
From Michael Jackson to Latvian Folk dancing,
all aboard the BOAT.
First up, my favorite. Improv Everywhere had
80 people dressed in blue shirts and khakis
walk into Best Buy. The store's employees
got so scared...yeah...they called the police.
Improv everywhere is also famous for Frozen
Grand Central, where 200 people just plain-old
stopped moving. They started moving eventually,
but if you'd rather split the difference,
the same group also has 225 people move in
slow motion at Home Depot.
Impressive, right?
Well, here are 3,000 people freezing in Paris.
T-Mobile was behind this flash mob, one of
the best recorded and documented ever.
But who cares about cool angles and editing
when you can have a Lightsaber flash mob
instead?
This happened in Poland. Not much is going
on until a stand-off ensues, a finger-gun
is pulled, everyone freaks out and starts
shooting, and people drop like flies.
Not enough skin for you?
Well, here's an effort from Flip. It might
be all "over when the fat lady sings," but
it all starts when the fat boy in a Speedo
dances.
If you wish these people would stop being
so vertical, I guess this Swedish dance troupe's
flash mob is more your style...A bunch of
people fall over Domino-style and then boogie
while lying on their backs.
Subtract the dancing and add a crazy guy with
a giant hammer and you've got this human Domino
chain.
But now, here's a bus driver in Europe whose
transport company surprised him with a birthday
flash mob. At first, a lone trumpeter makes
him go "Whaaa?" But then a woman starts singing
to him, more people join in, and once he starts
to get it, he drives right into a surprise
Bday party for himself.
I leave you today with some romance.
This guy organized an entire flash mob in
New York, so that when he proposed and she
said "yes," everyone would clap and then join
in with the dance explosion celebration.
So, there you go. What's the best flash mob
of all time? Let me know what you think below,
and if you have an idea for a future flash
mob that you think would be even better, let
me know what it would be, how it would work,
and why it would rule.
And, as always guys, thanks for watching.